Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode deals with a crime committed against a child. It won't be suitable for all listeners. The Teixeira Mendonça family lived in the northern Portuguese town of Lozada, 40 kilometres east from the country's striking and sun-baked coastline. Situated in the economically developed Porto district, Lozada is known for hosting championship motor racing events on a circuit just outside of town. It features remnants of
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要帮助，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的罪案。并非适合所有听众。特谢拉·门多萨（Teixeira Mendonça）一家住在葡萄牙北部小镇洛扎达，距离该国迷人且阳光普照的海岸线向东40公里。洛扎达位于经济发达的波尔图地区，以在镇郊的一条赛道上举办锦标赛赛车活动而闻名。这里保留着
its rich ancient history, with heritage monuments and sites including churches, manors, and courts dating back to the Middle Ages. Lozada maintains its strong agricultural tradition, with sprawling rural farm and bushland intersected by winding highways that lead to inland municipalities. intersected by winding highways that lead to inland municipalities. The Teixeira Mendonca family, helmed by Patriarch Manuel and his wife Filomena, were well known and regarded within the local community. By the late 90s, the couple had two children, an 8-year-old daughter named Karina and a son, 11- old Uy Pedro. Born on January 28 1987, Uy Pedro was an affectionate and happy child who was the life of the party. A devoted animal lover, he accumulated
其丰富的古代历史遗迹，文化遗产古迹和景点包括可以追溯到中世纪的教堂、庄园和法院。洛扎达保持着浓厚的农业传统，广阔的乡村农场和灌木丛与通往内陆城市的蜿蜒公路交织在一起。通往内陆城市的蜿蜒公路交织在一起。由大家长曼努埃尔（Manuel）和他的妻子菲洛梅纳（Filomena）掌舵的特谢拉·门多萨一家在当地社区广为人知且备受尊敬这对夫妇在90年代末育有两个孩子，8岁的女儿名叫卡丽娜（Karina），11岁的儿子叫瑞·佩德罗（Rui Pedro）。瑞·佩德罗于1987年1月28日出生，是一个深情且快乐的孩子，总是聚会上的开心果。他是一个狂热的动物爱好者，收集了
a menagerie at home, adopting so many canaries that he was forced to give some to his grandparents. many canaries that he was forced to give some to his grandparents. He once brought a squirrel home and made a treehouse for it, though was left devastated when it escaped the next day. When he wasn't caring for animals, Boy Pedro loved riding his bicycle, skateboarding, and helping with handiwork and electrical projects at home. A keen soccer player, he dreamed of playing professionally when he grew up. His life was full of jokes and laughter, with Philomena describing her son's laugh as contagious. She admired his imagination, a quality she observed during his long bubble baths and when he attempted to use a fork as a makeshift television antenna.
家里的一个小动物园，收养了太多的金丝雀，以至于他不得不把一些送给祖父母。收养了太多的金丝雀，以至于他不得不把一些送给祖父母。他曾把一只松鼠带回家，并为它搭了一个树屋，不过当第二天松鼠逃跑时，他伤心欲绝。当他不在照顾动物时，男孩佩德罗喜欢骑自行车、玩滑板，以及在家帮忙做手工和电器项目。作为一个热衷于踢足球的孩子，他梦想着长大后成为一名职业球员。他的生活充满了笑话和欢笑，菲洛梅纳形容她儿子的笑声极具感染力。她钦佩他的想象力，这是她在儿子漫长的泡泡浴中以及他试图用叉子当作临时电视天线时观察到的品质。
Filomena worked at her father's driving school directly opposite the family home, making it convenient for her children to stop by if they needed to speak with her during office hours. On Wednesday March 4 1998, shortly after 2pm, Filomena was busy working when Rui Pedro arrived. He'd just finished lunch and had cycled over seeking permission to spend the rest of the afternoon taking a car ride with his friend, Afonso Dias. Dias was a 22-year-old truck driver who had become close with Filomena's family after obtaining his driver's licence from her school three years earlier. His own family was burdened by financial struggles, which elicited a great deal of sympathy from Filomena. She provided Deix with clothes and
菲洛梅纳在她父亲的驾校工作，驾校就在他们家正对面，这让她的孩子们如果需要在办公时间与她说话时可以很方便地顺道过来。1998年3月4日星期三下午2点刚过，菲洛梅纳正忙于工作，瑞·佩德罗到了。他刚吃完午饭，骑着自行车过来，请求允许和他的朋友阿方索·迪亚斯（Afonso Dias）一起度过下午剩下的时间去兜风。迪亚斯是一名22岁的卡车司机，三年前从菲洛梅纳的驾校取得驾照后，与菲洛梅纳一家变得亲近。他自己的家庭背负着财务困境，这引起了菲洛梅纳极大的同情。她给迪亚斯提供衣服，并
let him assist at the driving school for extra money. Deyesh soon befriended Filomena's children and she trusted him to drive Juipedru and Karina to school most days. Juipedru was particularly enthusiastic about his new friend, who seemed cool and exciting to the 11-year-old by virtue of being older. Despite their significant age difference, Deish was regarded as childish and immature, which made him relatable to Huy Pedro. According to Deish, the two were like brothers. Yet, not everyone in the Teixeira-Mendonza household approved of their friendship. Huy Pedro's father Manuel and his maternal grandfather Jose were troubled by the 11-year age gap between the two, as well as Dias' habit of smoking cigarettes in Huy Pedro's company.
让他协助驾校工作以赚取外快。迪亚斯很快与菲洛梅纳的孩子们成为了朋友，她信任他，大部分日子都让他开车送瑞·佩德罗和卡丽娜去学校。瑞·佩德罗对他的新朋友表现得格外热情，这个11岁的男孩因为对方年纪较大，觉得他很酷、很令人兴奋。尽管他们年龄相差悬殊，但迪亚斯被认为很幼稚、不成熟，这让他和瑞·佩德罗很有共同语言。据迪亚斯说，两人就像兄弟一样。然而，特谢拉·门多萨家并不是所有人都赞成他们的友谊。瑞·佩德罗的父亲曼努埃尔和他的外公何塞（Jose）对两人之间11岁的年龄差距，以及迪亚斯在瑞·佩德罗面前抽烟的习惯感到担忧。
Manuel expressed his concerns to his wife on multiple occasions, and although Filomena regarded Dias as harmless, she respected her husband's grievances and started limiting the time Juipedru and Diez spent alone together. Therefore, she denied her son's request to go driving with Diez that afternoon. Juipedru was unhappy about his mother's decision but ultimately accepted it. Filomena reminded him that he had a tutoring lesson at 5pm and suggested he play in the vacant field behind her office in the meantime. The large space was framed by dry grass, trees and shrubs and contained a circular dirt track occasionally used for horse racing. Although the field was surrounded by main roads, cars didn't usually
曼努埃尔曾多次向妻子表达他的担忧，尽管菲洛梅纳认为迪亚斯无害，但她尊重丈夫的不满，并开始限制瑞·佩德罗和迪亚斯单独相处的时间。因此，她拒绝了儿子那天下午和迪亚斯去兜风的请求。瑞·佩德罗对母亲的决定很不高兴，但最终还是接受了。菲洛梅纳提醒他下午5点有一个辅导课，并建议他在此期间去她办公室后面的空地上玩。这片宽阔的空地四周环绕着枯草、树木和灌木，里面有一个偶尔用于赛马的圆形土质跑道。虽然这片空地被主干道环绕，但汽车通常不会
access the area, making it a popular place for children to play. Fui Pedro did as his mother told, waving goodbye as he happily pedalled off on his bike towards the field. The End Nearly four hours later, as 6pm approached, Philomena and Manuel received a phone call from Rui Pedro's tutor, informing them that he had not turned up for his 5 o'clock lesson. This came as a surprise, as he had never missed a tutoring session before. The 11-year-old suffered from epilepsy that required daily medication and fears soon grew that he may have suffered an attack. If untreated, a seizure could cause severe brain damage or worse. A search party was quickly formed and local residents were asked if they had seen the boy. A neighbour revealed that at around 3pm they had found Rui Pedro's bicycle amongst the bushes
进入该地区，使其成为孩子们玩耍的热门地点。瑞·佩德罗照着母亲的话做了，挥手告别，开心地骑着自行车向空地驶去。结束。将近四个小时后，随着下午6点的临近，菲洛梅纳和曼努埃尔接到了瑞·佩德罗辅导老师的电话，通知他们他没有去上5点的课程。这让人感到意外，因为他以前从未缺席过辅导课。这名11岁的男孩患有癫痫，需要每天服药，人们很快开始担心他可能发病了。如果不加以治疗，发作可能会导致严重的脑损伤或更严重的后果。搜救队迅速组建，并向当地居民询问是否见过这个男孩。一位邻居透露，大约下午3点，他们在办公室后面的空地
in the vacant field behind Filomena's office. His family contacted the National Public Guard, Portugal's military police who were responsible for civil law enforcement, and a wide-scale search was initiated. The police combed the streets of Lozada with assistance from local firemen, residents, and specially trained police dogs, but failed to uncover any other sign of the young boy. Three local boys came forward to report that as they were playing football together in the vacant field earlier in the afternoon, Huy Pedro arrived on his bike and joined them. At around 3pm, a black vehicle drove onto the racetrack and pulled up alongside Huy Pedro, who chatted with the male driver
灌木丛中发现了瑞·佩德罗的自行车。他的家人联系了葡萄牙负责民事执法的国家共和国卫队（宪兵队），并展开了大规模搜寻。警方在当地消防员、居民和受过专门训练的警犬的协助下，对洛扎达的街道进行了搜查，但没有发现任何关于这个小男孩的其他踪迹。三名当地男孩站出来报告说，当天下午早些时候，当他们在空地上一起踢足球时，瑞·佩德罗骑着自行车过来加入了他们。大约下午3点，一辆黑色的汽车开上赛道，停在瑞·佩德罗身旁，他与男司机聊了几句
before gesturing to his friends that he wouldn't be playing with them. He climbed into the car, leaving his bicycle behind. The children identified the driver as 22-year-old Alfonso Dias, who they said had been fixated on Jui Pedro over the past couple of weeks, constantly asking where he was, who he was with, and what his upcoming plans were. Jui Pedro's younger sister, Karina, also recalled that earlier that year, Dias had taken photographs of her and her brother, something he'd never done before. something he'd never done before. Several other witnesses also reported having seen Rui Pedro speaking to Afonso Dias at the field that afternoon. Dias was cited driving a black
然后向他的朋友们示意他不和他们一起玩了。他爬上了车，把自行车留在了原地。孩子们认出司机是22岁的阿方索·迪亚斯，他们说迪亚斯在过去几周里一直盯着瑞·佩德罗，不断询问他在哪里、他和谁在一起、他接下来的计划是什么。瑞·佩德罗的小妹妹卡丽娜也回忆说，今年早些时候，迪亚斯给她和哥哥拍了照片，这是他以前从未做过的事。这是他以前从未做过的事。其他几位目击者也报告说，那天下午在空地上看到瑞·佩德罗与阿方索·迪亚斯交谈。据目击者称，迪亚斯驾驶着一辆黑色的
Fiat Uno that belonged to his brother, who confirmed he had loaned the vehicle to Dias so he could take it for its annual roadworthy test, a mandatory practice in Portugal for vehicles over eight years old. However, records revealed Dias didn't attend the scheduled inspection. Police quickly located Dias. Pui Pedro wasn't with him and he claimed not to know where the missing boy was. Dias was taken to the Lozada police station for further questioning, where he denied giving Hui Pedro a ride, claiming he had only seen the boy for five minutes between 1.50 and 1.55pm. After this brief encounter, he drove alone to the nearby city of Pacos de Ferreira, located about 15 minutes
菲亚特乌诺（Fiat Uno），这辆车属于他的哥哥，哥哥证实他把车借给了迪亚斯，以便他能带车去进行年度道路适宜性检测，这是葡萄牙对车龄超过八年的车辆的强制性做法。然而，记录显示迪亚斯没有参加预定的检查。警方迅速找到了迪亚斯。瑞·佩德罗不在他身边，他声称不知道失踪的男孩在哪里。迪亚斯被带到洛扎达警察局接受进一步讯问，他在那里否认曾搭载过瑞·佩德罗，声称在下午1点50分到1点55分之间只见过这个男孩五分钟。在这短暂的相遇之后，他独自开车前往大约15分钟车程外的帕科斯-德费雷拉（Pacos de Ferreira）附近城市。
west, where he parked outside a pharmacy. He sat in the car for a while before walking around town, looking at the shop windows. He then drove the short distance to his girlfriend's home in the nearby town of Friamongi, arriving at 6.45pm. There, he received a phone call from his sister informing that Uypedru was missing. Uypedru's distraught grandfather Jose was also at the police station awaiting news. In a desperate bid to locate his grandson, he confronted Diez and offered him anything he wanted to disclose Huy Pedro's whereabouts. Diez began to cry, insisting he didn't know where the 11-year-old was. Then, all of a sudden, he gave police anonymous warning, telling them Huy Pedro could already be
西方，他在一家药店外停车。他在车里坐了一会儿，然后四处闲逛，看着商店的橱窗。随后，他开车前往位于附近弗里亚蒙吉小镇的女友家中，于下午6点45分抵达。在那里，他接到姐姐的电话，得知于佩德鲁失踪了。于佩德鲁悲痛欲绝的祖父何塞也在警察局等待消息。为了寻找孙子，他绝望地质问迪斯，并提出满足迪斯提出的任何要求以换取乌伊·佩德罗的下落。迪斯开始哭泣，坚称他不知道这名11岁的男孩在哪里。突然之间，他向警方发出了匿名警告，告诉他们乌伊·佩德罗可能已经
very far away and they should, quote, close the borders. Diez was also accosted by Rui Pedro's young cousin, Joao André, who began telling officers about an encounter the two boys had with Diez the day. Diasch warned him to shut up, but Andre was undeterred, explaining that Diasch had invited them to quote, go to the prostitutes. Diasch allegedly told the young boys to meet him at the field near the driving school the following day, where he would pick them up. When March 4 arrived, Andrei's mother wouldn't let him leave the house, so he missed the meeting. A local firefighter named Maria was one of many who witnessed Juan Pedro get into a black car at the field that afternoon. When she visited the local
去得很远了，他们应该，引用原话，关闭边境。迪斯还遭到若昂·安德烈（Rui Pedro的年轻表弟）的质问，后者开始向警官们讲述这两个男孩前一天与迪斯相遇的经过。迪亚施警告他闭嘴，但安德烈并未退缩，解释说迪亚施曾邀请他们，引用原话，去找妓女。迪亚施据称告诉两个男孩第二天在驾校附近的田野里见他，他会去接他们。3月4日到了，安德烈的母亲不让他出门，所以他错过了这次会面。当地一名叫玛丽亚的消防员是当天下午目击胡安·佩德罗上了一辆黑色汽车的众多目击者之一。当她去当地
police station to provide a report, she ran into Alfonso Dias and recognised him as the car's driver and informed officers of her discovery. This rattled Dias, who confronted Maria at the fire station following their encounter. He was visibly worried and bombarded her with questions pertaining to the ongoing investigation, including whether she knew what his car looked like. Meanwhile, Huy Pedro's disappearance had made local news, with reports describing him as 4 foot 11 inches tall, weighing approximately 45 kilograms, with short brown hair, dark eyes, and suntanned skin. This description was accompanied by a picture of him flashing a smile that revealed his distinctively large front teeth. A local
警察局做笔录时，她遇到了阿方索·迪亚斯，认出他是那辆车的司机，并将自己的发现告知了警官。这让迪亚斯感到惊慌，他在他们相遇后在消防局质问了玛丽亚。他显得忧心忡忡，向她抛出一连串关于正在进行的调查的问题，包括她是否知道他的车长什么样。与此同时，于佩德罗失踪的消息已经登上当地新闻，报道称他身高4英尺11英寸，体重约45公斤，留着短棕发，黑眼睛，晒黑的皮肤。伴随这一描述的是一张他咧嘴微笑的照片，露出了他标志性的大门牙。当地
sex worker named Alsina recognised the boy in the photograph and immediately contacted authorities. According to Alsina, on the afternoon of March 4, she was working along the Strada Nacional 106, a highway leading into the town of Lushtoza, 10 kilometres northwest of Lozada. A man in a black car had pulled up beside her, accompanied by a child she now believed had been Jui Pedro. The man asked if Alsina was working and offered to pay her 2,000 skudus to have sex with the boy, whom he said was 14 years old. The boy got out of the car but was obviously distressed and started to cry. Alsina led him into the woods but didn't initiate any physical contact, instead sympathising with him and spending the next 15 minutes trying to calm him down.
一名叫阿尔西娜的性工作者认出了照片中的男孩，并立即联系了当局。据阿尔西娜称，3月4日下午，她正在通往卢什托扎镇的106号国道旁工作，该镇位于洛扎达西北10公里处。一辆黑色汽车在她旁边停下，车上还有一个她现在认为就是朱伊·佩德罗的孩子。这名男子问阿尔西娜是否在工作，并提出付给她2000埃斯库多与这个男孩发生性关系，他说这个男孩14岁。男孩下了车，但明显感到痛苦并开始哭泣。阿尔西娜把他带进树林，但没有进行任何身体接触，而是同情他，并花了接下来15分钟试图让他平静下来。
The boy said the man was his uncle who was forcing him to visit sex workers against his will. Alsina asked if his mother knew, to which the boy replied no. He continued to sob and Alsina asked if his mother knew, to which the boy replied no. He continued to sob and Alsina gave him a hug, promising he would be okay. She walked the child back to the car and watched as it drove away, under the impression that the driver was heading to a brothel 500 metres away. a brothel 500 metres away. Despite multiple witness statements indicating otherwise, the police were not convinced that Juipedru had been abducted. Instead, they treated his disappearance as a search and rescue case, certain he had either collapsed somewhere or wandered off too far and gotten lost. Though the Teixeira
男孩说这个男子是他的叔叔，强迫他违背意愿去见性工作者。阿尔西娜问他的母亲是否知道，男孩回答说不知道。他继续啜泣，阿尔西娜问他的母亲是否知道，男孩回答说不知道。他继续啜泣，阿尔西娜拥抱了他，承诺他会没事的。她把孩子送回车旁，看着车子开走，以为司机正前往500米外的一家妓院。以为司机正前往500米外的一家妓院。尽管多份目击证词表明并非如此，但警方并不确信朱伊佩德鲁是被绑架了。相反，他们将他的失踪视为搜救案件，确信他要么在某处晕倒，要么走得太远而迷路了。尽管特谢拉
Mendonça family begged authorities to act with urgency, the district court was unable to intervene unless it was confirmed that an abduction had taken place. Roughly 24 hours after Huipedru's disappearance, several agents of the judicialicial Police finally arrived in Lozada to assist in the ongoing search. As the National Criminal Police Agency, the Judicial Police were responsible for investigating serious crimes such as homicides, kidnappings, organised crime, and terrorism. Over the following days, the local neighbourhoods, wells, rivers, and outlying scrublands were searched repeatedly. Missing person posters featuring a photograph of a smiling Rui Pedro wearing a light grey t-shirt were distributed and the case soon gained national
门多萨一家恳求当局紧急行动，但地区法院在确认发生绑架之前无法介入。在于佩德鲁失踪大约24小时后，司法警察的好几名特工终于抵达洛扎达协助搜寻工作。作为国家刑事警察机构，司法警察负责调查谋杀、绑架、有组织犯罪和恐怖主义等严重犯罪。在接下来的几天里，当地的居民区、水井、河流和偏远的灌木丛被反复搜寻。印有微笑的鲁伊·佩德罗穿着浅灰色T恤照片的寻人启事被分发出去，该案很快引起了全国媒体的关注。
media attention. The young boy's disappearance sparked an overwhelming sense of communal grief, with many Portuguese news articles referring to the missing child as our boy, or our little Huipedru. The intense media coverage prompted an onslaught of calls to the Teixeira Mendonca family. People claimed to have Huy Pedro in their possession, with some callers demanding a ransom for his safe return. One male caller claimed to be the boy's kidnapper and demanded that Filomena undress in front of her window in order to get her son back. A clairvoyant informed the family about a vision they'd received of Juipedru's head in a river. Filomena received the most horrifying call, in which a child repeatedly yelled Mama into the receiver before the phone abruptly disconnected.
这个年轻男孩的失踪引发了压倒性的集体悲痛，许多葡萄牙新闻文章将这名失踪儿童称为我们的男孩，或我们的小于佩德罗。密集的媒体报道引发了打给特谢拉·门多萨一家的狂轰滥炸般的电话。人们声称他们控制着于佩德罗，一些来电者索要赎金以确保他安全归来。一名男来电者声称自己是男孩的绑架者，并要求菲洛梅娜在窗前脱衣服才能找回儿子。一位灵媒向家人透露了他们收到的关于于佩德罗的头部在河里的幻象。菲洛梅娜接到了最可怕的电话，电话里一个孩子对着话筒反复尖叫妈妈，然后电话突然挂断了。
She was certain the voice was her son's. connected. She was certain the voice was her son's. Despite a judge ordering that the family's phone calls be placed under surveillance, none were traced. Police refused to investigate them further, saying they hadn't heard the calls themselves and didn't have the means of locating the people responsible for making them. The family suggested possible methods which were dismissed by the police, who explained those strategies were, quote, only in the movies. The police also disregarded the multiple witness accounts that placed Huipedru in the company of Afonso Dias on the afternoon of his disappearance.
她确信这个声音是她儿子的。挂断了。她确信这个声音是她儿子的。尽管法官下令对家长的电话进行监控，但没有一个电话被追踪到。警方拒绝进一步调查，称他们自己没有听到这些电话，也没有手段定位负责拨打电话的人。家属提出了可能的侦查方法，但遭到警方驳回，警方解释说这些策略，引用原话，只在电影里出现。警方还无视了多份证词，这些证词指出于佩德罗在失踪当天下午与阿方索·迪亚斯在一起。
Huipedru in the company of Afonso Dias on the afternoon of his disappearance. Dias maintained his version of events and promptly moved away from Lozada, with nothing else done to pursue him further as a suspect. Although Filomena had limited the time Dias spent with her son, neighbours had since informed her that the two had been meeting in secret. Prior to Rui Pedro's disappearance, Filomena had also noticed a shift in Dias's demeanour. He was reserved, which at the time she had attributed to the fact he was maturing and had recently gotten a girlfriend. Now, she suspected he had been planning to harm her son for a while and was withholding important information from investigators. The Teixeira Mendonca family
于佩德罗在失踪当天下午与阿方索·迪亚斯在一起。迪亚斯坚持自己的说法，并迅速搬离了洛扎达，此后再没有采取任何行动来进一步追查他作为嫌疑人的责任。尽管菲洛梅娜限制了迪亚斯和她儿子相处的时间，但邻居们后来告诉她，两人一直在秘密会面。在鲁伊·佩德罗失踪之前，菲洛梅娜也注意到迪亚斯态度上的转变。他变得内向，当时她将其归因于他正在成熟且最近交了女朋友。现在，她怀疑他策划伤害她的儿子已经有一段时间了，并且向调查人员隐瞒了重要信息。特谢拉·门多萨一家
visited all the key locations to search for clues, but found no trace of Ruy Pedro, and a month passed with no further developments in the case. a month passed with no further developments in the case. In April 1998, Portuguese journalist Nuno Rogero travelled to Disneyland in Paris with his wife and children to write an article about the famous theme park for Portuguese women's magazine, Caras. The article was published along with several photographs documenting the Rogero's trip, including one taken by a camera positioned on a ride called Pinocchio's Daring Journey. In the photo, Nunu's wife, young son, and daughter are seated together in the front row of the ride's carriage, while Nunu is seated alone in the middle
走访了所有关键地点寻找线索，但没有找到任何关于鲁伊·佩德罗的踪迹，一个月过去了，案件没有任何进一步的进展。一个月过去了，案件没有任何进一步的进展。1998年4月，葡萄牙记者努诺·罗热罗和妻子及孩子一起前往巴黎迪士尼乐园，为葡萄牙女性杂志《卡拉斯》撰写一篇关于这个著名主题公园的文章。这篇文章与几张记录罗热罗旅行的照片一起发表，其中包括一张由安装在名为“匹诺曹历险记”的游乐设施上的相机拍摄的照片。照片中，努诺的妻子、幼子和女儿一起坐在游乐设施车厢的第一排，而努诺一人坐在中间
row holding a camcorder. Behind him, in the third and final row, a little boy was seated next to an older man. The boy, whose face was turned slightly to the left, had tanned skin, brown hair, and was dressed in a dark zip-up jacket. He was sitting next to a Caucasian man who appeared to be aged in his forties with balding dark hair and was wearing a red hooded jacket. An observant Cardiff's reader noticed the boy looked remarkably like Huy Pedro. Upon seeing the image for themselves, Filomena and Manuel were certain it was their son. The Portuguese police confiscated the photograph for further analysis and sought CCTV footage taken during the ride, but Euro Disney's video security system hadn't
手里拿着一台摄像机。在他身后的第三排也是最后一排，一个小男孩坐在一个老男人旁边。小男孩的脸稍微向左转，皮肤晒黑，留着棕色头发，穿着一件深色拉链夹克。他坐在一个看起来四十多岁、谢顶、留着深色头发的白人男子旁边，男子穿着一件红色连帽衫。卡迪夫的一位细心读者注意到，这个男孩长得酷似鲁伊·佩德罗。菲洛梅娜和曼努埃尔看到这张照片后，确信这就是他们的儿子。葡萄牙警方没收了这张照片以便进一步分析，并调取了游乐设施运行期间拍摄的监控录像，但欧洲迪士尼的视频安全系统当天并未
been functioning on the day the photo was taken and no footage existed. The balding man was largely obscured by Nunu and his camcorder, making him difficult to identify. There were conflicting reports as to whether he was identified, with some local sources claiming he was a bar owner or security guard from Portugal's Porto district, of which Lozada was situated, but the lead didn't progress any further. For the many Portuguese people who believed the boy in the photo was indeed Rui Pedro, the picture supported the theory that he had been abducted and was still alive. Speculation arose that Afonso Dias had sold Juipedru to traffickers who quickly ferried him abroad, a hypothesis seemingly bolstered
正常运行，因此没有留下任何录像。那个谢顶的男子大部分被努努和他的摄像机挡住了，很难辨认。关于他是否被认出，有相互矛盾的报道，一些当地消息来源称他是葡萄牙波尔图地区的一名酒吧老板或保安，洛扎达就位于该地区，但这条线索没有取得进一步进展。对于许多坚信照片中的男孩确实是鲁伊·佩德罗的葡萄牙人来说，这张照片支持了这样的理论：他被绑架了，并且仍然活着。有猜测称阿方索·迪亚斯将若伊佩德鲁卖给了贩子，贩子迅速将他偷运到了国外，这一假设似乎得到了
by Dias warning police to close the borders. Members of the Teixeira-Mendonza family set out overseas, spending all of their money travelling to various locations in search of Rui Pedro, but came no closer to finding him. Filomena Teixeira later said, It's hard to remember that moment I saw the photograph and everything I felt. I don't know who to blame, but neither the picture nor the other clues or steps taken in Paris came to anything. The same month the Euro Disney photo was published, 1300 kilometres northeast of Lousada in the city of London, the British National Crime Squad initiated a large scale covert inquiry called Operation Cathedral. The inquiry aimed to track down the elusive
迪亚斯警告警方关闭边境的言论的支持。特谢拉-门多萨一族的成员远赴海外，花光了所有的钱前往各地寻找鲁伊·佩德罗，但离找到他依然遥遥无期。菲洛梅娜·特谢拉后来表示：“很难记起我看到那张照片时的那一刻以及我所有的感受。我不知道该怪谁，但在巴黎拍摄的照片以及采取的其他线索和步骤都没有任何结果。”就在欧洲迪士尼照片发表的同一个月，在距离洛扎达东北1300公里的伦敦市，英国国家犯罪局发起了一项名为“大教堂行动”的大规模秘密调查。该调查旨在追踪行踪诡秘的
members of an online pedophile ring known as the Wonderland Club, who had distributed more than 750,000 illicit images of children. This investigation, covered in episode 115 of Casefile, led to the arrest of 29-year-old Kent-based computer technician and volunteer youth leader, Gavin Seegers. Amongst his large collection of child exploitation material were images showing the abuse of a young boy, labelled with the name Billy. Following the completion of Operation Cathedral in September 1998, the British National Crime Squad sanitised many of the images and compiled a database of victims' faces for investigative agencies worldwide to use in their efforts to identify, locate and save the
一个名为“仙境俱乐部”的在线恋童癖团伙的成员，该团伙分发了超过75,000张非法的儿童色情图片。这项调查在《案宗》第115集中进行了报道，导致29岁的肯特郡计算机技术员兼青年志愿者领袖加文·西格斯被捕。在他的庞大儿童剥削材料收藏中，有一些显示虐待一个小男孩的图片，上面贴着比利的名字。随着1998年9月“大教堂行动”的结束，英国国家犯罪局对许多图片进行了脱敏处理，并编制了一个受害者面部数据库，供全球执法机构在努力识别、定位和拯救
children featured. In 2000, international authorities believed the boy referred to as Billy in Wonderland's collection bore a striking resemblance to missing Portuguese boy, Rui Pedro. They contacted Filomena Teixeira and requested that she view the images herself to see if a positive identification could be made. As the images could only be viewed in Geneva, Switzerland, a date was scheduled for Filomena and Manuel to visit in 2001. They were briefed about what to expect prior to their arrival, including details of the level of abuse featured in the content. Upon seeing the images of Billy, Philomena confirmed it was indeed Huy Pedro.
这些儿童时使用。2000年，国际权威机构认为“仙境”藏品中被称为比利的男孩与失踪的葡萄牙男孩鲁伊·佩德罗惊人地相似。他们联系了菲洛梅娜·特谢拉，请求她亲自查看这些图片，看看能否做出明确的辨认。由于这些图片只能在瑞士日内瓦查看，因此安排了菲洛梅娜和曼努埃尔在2001年访问的日期。他们在抵达前听取了关于预期情况的简报，包括内容中涉及的虐待程度的细节。在看到比利的图片后，菲洛梅娜确认这确实是若伊·佩德罗。
Although the content was distressing, it increased the couple's hope that their son was still alive. it increased the couple's hope that their son was still alive. As media reported on the positive identification, authorities feared it would spur Jorge Pedro's abductors to murder him out of panic. Gavin Seegers and his cohort, fellow Wonderland member Ian Baldock, were interrogated by Interpol, but both denied knowing who sent them the photos. The poor quality of the images made it difficult for authorities to pinpoint when or where they were taken and their origin was not able to be determined. Puy Pedro was one of only a few children who were positively identified in the images shared within the Wonderland Club.
尽管这些内容令人痛心，但它增加了这对夫妇对儿子仍然还活着的希望。随着媒体对这一明确辨认进行报道，当局担心这会惊慌失措地促使若热·佩德罗的绑架者谋杀他。加文·西格斯和他的同伙、仙境俱乐部的同伴伊安·巴尔多克受到了国际刑警组织的审讯，但两人都否认知道是谁给他们发送了这些照片。由于照片质量很差，当局很难确定它们是何时或何地拍摄的，其来源也无法确定。若伊·佩德罗是在仙境俱乐部共享的图片中被明确辨认出的极少数儿童之一。
identified in the images shared within the Wonderland Club. The other known victims included six children from the United Kingdom, seven from the United States, one from Chile, and another from Argentina. The investigation into Huipedru's disappearance slowed due to a lack of credible leads, but the case held the public's interest to such a degree that numerous sightings continued to be reported years after his abduction, none of which were definitively confirmed. At one stage, a Portuguese man named José de Matos was approaching his release from prison for swindling when he announced that he knew the whereabouts of the missing child. He told authorities Juipedru was taken to the city of Visiu on the night of his disappearance, 165 kilometres southeast of Lozada, and was later kept by the owner of a grocery store in England.
在仙境俱乐部共享的图片中被明确辨认出。其他已知的受害者包括来自英国的六名儿童、来自美国的七名、来自智力的一名以及来自阿根廷的另一名。由于缺乏可靠的线索，对若伊佩德罗失踪案的调查放缓了，但该案在公众中引起了极大的兴趣，以至于在他被绑架多年后仍不断有人报告目击事件，但没有一件得到最终证实。有一段时间，一个名叫何塞·德马托斯的葡萄牙男子因诈骗即将刑满释放，当时他宣布他知道失踪儿童的下落。他告诉当局，若伊佩德罗在他失踪当晚被带到了距离洛扎达东南165公里的维苏市，后来被英国的一家杂货店老板收留。
His story was convincing and de Martus promised to retrieve the child upon his release. As he was due to be paroled at the time, authorities were certain it wasn't just a ploy for the inmate to escape prison. Sparing no expense, the Teixeira Mendonca family provided the Matush with an unlimited credit card, cell phone, and a Volvo S80 vehicle to facilitate the journey to bring Rui Pedro home. The Matush kept in touch with the family, first heading to Spain, before continuing onwards to England, where he phoned Rui Pedro's grandfather back in Portugal, stating, England where he phoned Hoi Pedro's grandfather back in Portugal stating,
他的故事很有说服力，德马图斯承诺一释放就找回这个孩子。由于他当时即将获得假释，当局确信这不仅仅是这名囚犯逃离监狱的诡计。特谢拉·门多萨家族不惜重金，向马图什提供了无限额信用卡、手机和一辆沃尔沃S80汽车，以协助他带鲁伊·佩德罗回家的旅程。马图什与该家庭保持着联系，首先前往西班牙，然后继续前往英国，在那里他给葡萄牙的鲁伊·佩德罗的祖父打电话，说：英国，他在那里给葡萄牙鲁伊·佩德罗的祖父打电话说：
Hello, I have in front of me the grandson of Mr Teixeira. He is eating an ice cream. The call prompted an emotional response from the desperate family. Yet, as the days passed, there was no further word from de Martus and suspicion grew. Authorities discovered that de Martus hadn't even left Portugal and that his entire story was a scam. He was ultimately convicted of fraud and served seven years in prison. Puyo Pedro's grandfather, José, maintained his belief that Afonso Dias was responsible for his grandson's disappearance. He had promised his daughter he would bring her son home no matter what, spending all of his money hiring private detectives and travelling to various countries, tirelessly searching for clues. In 2003, Jose was killed in a tractor accident. His sudden death was another devastating blow to Filomena, who credited her father as giving her the strength to carry on.
“喂，我面前就是特谢拉先生的孙子。他在吃冰淇淋。”这通电话引发了这个绝望家庭的情感反应。然而，随着日子一天天过去，德马图斯再也没有音讯，怀疑也随之加剧。当局发现德马图斯甚至没有离开葡萄牙，他的整个故事完全是一场骗局。他最终被判欺诈罪，并在监狱服刑七年。若伊·佩德罗的祖父何塞坚持认为阿方索·迪亚斯对孙子的失踪负有责任。他曾向女儿保证，无论如何都要把她的儿子带回家，花光了所有的钱聘请私人侦探，去过不同的国家，不知疲倦地寻找线索。2003年，何塞在一次拖拉机事故中丧生。他的突然离世对菲洛梅娜来说是又一次毁灭性的打击，她认为父亲给予了她坚持下去的力量。
Jose was commended by the Lozada community for his ongoing determination and for ensuring the search efforts to find Pui Pedro continued. That same year, a major Portuguese pedophile ring was exposed after nine survivors came forward to report being subjected to sexual abuse during their time at state-run orphanages known as Casa Pia, or Houses of the Pious. Members of the ring included doctors, lawyers, a prominent television host, an ambassador, and other high-profile individuals. During the investigation, a former sex worker claimed to have seen Huipedru at a boarding house in the Portuguese capital city of Lisbon and on a
何塞因其坚持不懈的决心以及确保寻找若伊·佩德罗的努力得以继续而受到洛扎达社区的表彰。同年，在九名幸存者站出来报告在被称为卡萨皮亚（Casa Pia）或“虔诚之家”的国营孤儿院期间遭受性虐待后，一个重大的葡萄牙恋童癖团伙被曝光。该团伙的成员包括医生、律师、一位著名的电视节目主持人、一位大使和其他备受瞩目的个人。在调查期间，一名曾从事性工作的前女子声称在葡萄牙首都里斯本的一家寄宿公寓里以及在
videotape that was later given to Carlos Silvanu, a significant member of the pedophile ring. Silvanu was a driver for the orphanages and his role within the group was to transport children from Casa Pia to the homes of abusers. He later confessed to 639 charges relating to child abuse and procuring children for others. Seven members were later tried, six of whom were convicted of using the orphanages to rape a number of teenage boys. The trial sent shockwaves through the country, but no definitive link between the pedophile ring and Hoi Pedru was ever identified. The alleged videotape featuring footage of the child was never found. Over the ensuing years, Hoi Pedru's loved ones criticised the nation's bureaucracy over what they regarded as a sloppy
后来交给卡洛斯·席尔瓦努的一段录像带中看到了若伊佩德罗，卡洛斯·席尔瓦努是该恋童癖团伙的重要成员。席尔瓦努是孤儿院的司机，他在集团中的角色是将儿童从卡萨皮亚运送到虐待者的家中。他后来对639项与虐待儿童和替他人物色儿童相关的指控供认不讳。随后有七名成员受审，其中六人因利用孤儿院强奸多名十几岁的男孩而被定罪。这场审判在全国引起了震撼，但恋童癖团伙与若伊·佩德罗之间从未确定任何明确的联系。据称载有该儿童录像画面的录像带也从未找到。在随后的几年里，若伊·佩德罗的亲人们批评国家的官僚体制，认为这是一次糟糕
and negligent investigation. Channel TVI journalist Anna Leal reported that authorities had failed to speak to important witnesses or follow-up leads that emerged during the early days of the case. In addition, Filomena Teixeira had been sexually harassed by an inspector of the judicial police during the initial stages of the investigation, which resulted in her filing a complaint Puyo Pedro was particularly close to his uncle and godfather, Carlos Teixeira, whom he idolised In 2007, Carlos thanked the public for their ongoing support and solidarity, saying the family had employed all possible means in the search for clues, including resorting to the use of mediums and other spiritualists in Portugal and abroad.
且疏忽的调查。TVII频道的记者安娜·莱尔报道称，当局未能与重要证人交谈，也未能跟进案件初期出现的线索。此外，在调查初期，菲洛梅娜·特谢拉曾遭到司法警察检查员的性骚扰，这导致她提出了申诉。若伊·佩德罗与他的叔叔兼教父卡洛斯·特谢拉特别亲近，他崇拜卡洛斯。2007年，卡洛斯感谢公众一直以来的支持和声援，称该家族为了寻找线索已经采用了所有可能的手段，包括求助于葡萄牙国内外的灵媒和其他灵媒。
They followed all instructions given by these alternative guides, including climbing mountains in the dark, visiting isolated abandoned houses, undergoing hypnotism, and participating in magic rituals, but to no result. At one stage, Philomena spent the night in a field after receiving word from her son's alleged captors that they were going to hand him over. Although she believed it was yet another con, her heart wouldn't let her miss the meeting. As anticipated, her hopes were dashed when no one showed. Although the botched investigation was a source of pain and frustration for the family, Carlos Teixeira remarked, I do not even feel entitled to say that I am harmed because my pain is so small
他们遵循了这些另类向导给出的所有指示，包括在黑暗中爬山、参观孤立的废弃房屋、接受催眠以及参加魔法仪式，但都没有结果。有一段时间，菲洛梅娜在接到她儿子的所谓绑架者称要将他交出来的消息后，在田野里过夜。尽管她认为这又是一场骗局，但她的内心却不让她错过这次会面。正如预期的那样，当没有人出现时，她的希望破灭了。尽管搞砸的调查给这个家庭带来了痛苦和沮丧，但卡洛斯·特谢拉评论说：“我甚至不觉得我有权说我受到了伤害，因为我的痛苦是如此微不足道
compared to what this child is going through. April 2007 marked nine years since Huipedru vanished. On the 28th of that month, Jerry and Kate McCann travelled from their home in Leicestershire, England, to a family resort in the coastal Portuguese village of Praia da Luz. Located in the Algarve region, 620 kilometres south of Lozada, the area was particularly popular with British tourists. Gerry and Kate brought their three children, two-year-old twins Sean and Amelie, and their three-year-old sister, Madeline. The McCann family were also joined by a group of friends and several of their young children.
与这个孩子正在经历的事情相比。”2007年4月，距离若伊佩德罗失踪已经过去了九年。当月28日，杰瑞和凯特·麦卡恩夫妇从他们位于英国莱斯特郡的家中出发，前往葡萄牙沿海村庄普拉亚达卢斯的一个家庭度假村。该地区位于阿尔加维地区，在洛扎达以南620公里处，深受英国游客的欢迎。杰瑞和凯特带着他们的三个孩子，两岁的双胞胎肖恩和阿梅莉，以及他们三岁的姐姐玛德琳。麦卡恩一家还与一群朋友及他们的几个年幼的孩子一起同行。
The group spent the next five days enjoying the resort's facilities. Thursday May 3 2007 was the penultimate day of their trip. Thursday May 3 2007 was the penultimate day of their trip. At 7pm, Cade and Jerry put the children to bed before going to meet their friends for an 8.30pm dinner. The restaurant was located 82 metres from their ground floor rental apartment. Every 30 minutes, one of the adults would take the short walk back to the residential block to check on their sleeping children. At 10pm, Kate entered her apartment and looked into her children's bedroom and noticed the window was open and Madeline was missing. The authorities were notified immediately and search parties quickly set out, but no trace of Madeline McCann has ever been found and the circumstances of her disappearance remain a mystery.
这群人花了两天时间享受度假村的设施。2007年5月3日星期四是他们旅行的倒数第二天。2007年5月3日星期四是他们旅行的倒数第二天。晚上7点，凯特和杰瑞把孩子们哄上床睡觉，然后去和朋友们会面，准备吃晚上8:30的晚餐。餐厅距离他们一楼的出租公寓有82米。每隔30分钟，其中一个成年人就会步行一小段路回到住宅区查看他们熟睡的孩子。晚上10点，凯特走进她的公寓，朝孩子们的卧室看去，发现窗户开着，玛德琳不见了。当局立即接到通知，搜救队迅速出发，但至今没有找到玛德琳·麦卡恩的任何踪迹，她失踪的细节仍然是个谜。
Rumours circulated that Madeline's case was connected to the disappearance of Rui Pedro, although it has been confirmed that Madeline was not featured in any images or videos confiscated from the Wonderland Club. Given that Afonso Dias' job as a truck driver required him to travel extensively around Portugal, he was also considered a suspect in Madeline's case. Filomena told newspaper 24 Horas, I immediately thought of my son, even though the cases are different, and I thought of Madeline's parents, the anguish they are suffering. The Teixeira Mendonca family sent the McCanns a letter, but never received a reply.
有传言称玛德琳的案件与鲁伊·佩德罗的失踪有关，尽管已经证实玛德琳并未出现在从仙境俱乐部没收的任何图片或视频中。鉴于阿方索·迪亚斯作为卡车司机的职业要求他在葡萄牙各地广泛奔波，他也因此被认为是玛德琳案件的嫌疑人。菲洛梅娜告诉《24小时》报纸：“我立刻想到了我的儿子，尽管案件不同，而且我想到了玛德琳的父母，他们正在遭受的痛苦。”特谢拉·门多萨家族给麦卡恩夫妇写了一封信，但从未收到回信。
As with Hui Pedru's case, a number of investigative mistakes were made from the outset of Madeline's disappearance, but her abduction received far more attention, resources, media coverage and funding. This disparity caused tensions between the McCanns and the Portuguese public, with newspaper headlines asking, what about our missing children? paper headlines asking, what about our missing children? Filomena Teixeira told journalists that while she was glad the police were taking great efforts to find Madeline, she felt it was unjust that the same efforts weren't being made to recover missing Portuguese children. She had been unaware that Portugal even had forensic police units until Madeline's disappearance, as their services had never been engaged in the search for her son.
与若伊·佩德罗的案件一样，玛德琳失踪案从一开始就犯了许多调查错误，但她的绑架案受到了更多的关注、资源、媒体报道和资金。这种差异导致了麦卡恩夫妇与葡萄牙公众之间的紧张关系，报纸头条问道：“那我们的失踪儿童呢？”报纸头条问道：“那我们的失踪儿童呢？”菲洛梅娜·特谢拉告诉记者，虽然她很高兴警方在寻找玛德琳方面做出了巨大努力，但她觉得没有为找回失踪的葡萄牙儿童做出同样的努力是不公平的。直到玛德琳失踪，她甚至不知道葡萄牙还有法医警察部队，因为在寻找她儿子的过程中从未动用过他们的服务。
Filomena told television news reporters, The McCanns have everything available to them, even a helicopter. I didn't have that nine years ago. I didn't have anything. In an interview with Carus magazine, she said, It is hard for me to see all the means available for this case when Pedro received none of this. I have the same right as Madeline's parents. I demand the same treatment for my son's case. Investigators promise me that my son's case is not forgotten. They work hard but have no
菲洛梅娜告诉电视新闻记者：“麦卡恩夫妇拥有他们所能拥有的一切，甚至还有一架直升机。九年前我没有。我什么也没有。”在接受《卡鲁斯》杂志采访时她说：“看到为这个案子准备的所有手段，而佩德罗却什么也没有得到，这让我很难受。我和玛德琳的父母享有同等的权利。我要求对我的儿子的案件进行同样的对待。调查人员向我保证，我儿子的案件并没有被遗忘。他们工作很努力，但没有
means. Our government has not yet realised that this is a real problem and that it requires real measures, such as a change of law and adequate means to investigate. Portuguese nationals believed that Hoi Pedro might have been found already if his case had been given the same amount of due diligence as the McCann investigation. The Vice President of the Algarve Tourist Board stated, There is no doubt that this case has a much higher profile because Madeline is British and was on holiday here and this is causing resentment amongst the Portuguese. Child protection campaigners alleged that corruption and complacency were
手段。我们的政府还没有意识到这是一个真正的问题，它需要真正的措施，比如修改法律和提供足够的调查手段。”葡萄牙国民认为，如果他的案件能像麦卡恩调查那样得到同等程度的尽职调查，若伊·佩德罗可能早就被找到了。阿尔加维旅游局副局长表示：“毫无疑问，这个案件具有更高的知名度，因为玛德琳是英国人，而且是在这里度假，这引起了葡萄牙人的不满。”儿童保护活动人士声称，腐败和自满情绪
rampant amongst Portuguese law enforcement, which allowed such kidnappings to continue. The founder of international child advocacy group Innocence in Danger stated that she had tried to set up an office in Portugal but eventually gave up because local authorities were reluctant about the idea. At the time of Madeleine McCann's disappearance, police were still distributing a photograph of Rui Pedro at age 11 rather than taking advantage of age progression technology to show what he might look like at age 20. Filomena insisted that police update her son's image to increase the likelihood of him being identified, but they refused. In response, several artists volunteered to create a portrait of what Hoi Pedru might look
在葡萄牙执法部门中十分猖獗，这使得此类绑架事件得以持续。国际儿童倡导组织“危险中的纯真”的创始人表示，她曾试图在葡萄牙设立办事处，但最终放弃了，因为当地当局对此事心存抗拒。在玛德琳·麦卡恩失踪时，警察仍在分发鲁伊·佩德罗11岁时的照片，而不是利用年龄推进技术来展示他20岁时的样子。菲洛梅娜坚决要求警方更新她儿子的照片，以增加他被辨认出的可能性，但他们拒绝了。作为回应，几位艺术家自愿创作了一幅展示若伊·佩德罗可能长相的肖像
like at 20 years old, with Filomena describing these illustrations as, quote, "...the best gift of recent times." On June 1 2007, Filomena attended an event for World Children's Day that aimed to raise awareness for missing minors. She told Caras magazine she felt Hoi Pedro wasn't in Portugal, adding, It is hard for me to imagine what he will be doing. I have been in psychiatric treatment because I start thinking about what happened or how he might be. I always imagine that I will find him in a way that I can still do something for him. Even if he is sick or fragile, I will help him recover and we will still have a future. Puyo Pedro's younger sister, Karina, who was now 18 years old,
就像在20岁时那样，菲洛梅娜将这些插画形容为“近期最好的礼物”。2007年6月1日，菲洛梅娜出席了一个旨在提高人们对失踪未成年人意识的儿童节活动。她告诉《Caras》杂志，她觉得鲁伊·佩德罗不在葡萄牙，并补充说：“我很难想象他在做什么。我一直在接受精神治疗，因为我总是开始回想发生了什么，或者他现在可能过得怎么样。我总是幻想着能以某种方式找到他，让我还能为他做点什么。即使他生病了或身体虚弱，我也会帮他康复，我们依然会有未来。”鲁伊·佩德罗的小妹妹卡丽娜当时已经18岁了，
still referred to her brother in the present tense and expressed her belief that he would return. In 2009, new hopes were ignited when, in the United States, kidnapping survivor Jacey Lee Dugard was found 18 years after she was abducted from a street near her Californian home in 1991. Covered in episode 33 of Case File, Jacey was held captive by convicted sex offender Philip Garrido and his wife Nancy in their home for almost two decades before she was discovered and rescued by law enforcement. Like Hui Pedro, Jacey was 11 years old at the time of her abduction. Like Hoi Pedro, Jacey was 11 years old at the time of her abduction. Her reappearance gave the Teixeira Mendonca family some encouragement about the ingenuity of investigators and fuelled hope that Hoi Pedro might still be found alive.
仍然用现在时称呼她的哥哥，并表达了她坚信哥哥会回来的信念。2009年，在美国，1991年在加州住所附近的街道上被绑架18年后，绑架幸存者杰西·李·杜加德（Jacey Lee Dugard）被找到，这重燃了人们的新希望。正如《档案》第33集所报道的那样，杰西被已被定罪的性犯罪者菲利普·加里多（Philip Garrido）和他的妻子南希在他们的家中囚禁了近二十年，直到她被执法部门发现并解救。和鲁伊·佩德罗一样，杰西在被绑架时也是11岁。和鲁伊·佩德罗一样，杰西在被绑架时也是11岁。她的重新出现给了特谢拉·门多萨（Teixeira Mendonca）一家一些关于调查人员才能的鼓舞，并燃起了鲁伊·佩德罗可能仍被活着找到的希望。
Two years later, a new police team based in Porto used witness statements taken during the crucial hours after Rui Pedro's disappearance to reconstruct what likely happened to him in the 24 hours following. As a result of these efforts, on February 11 2011, Portugal's Central Department of Criminal Investigation and Prosecution indicted Afonso Dias. Dias, the long-time prime suspect in the now 13-year-old case, was charged with aggravated abduction. Ricardo Sarr Fernandes, the lawyer for the Teixeira Mendonça family, lamented the very large delay the public prosecutor's office had taken in issuing the indictment, but welcomed it as an opportunity of hope for Huy Pedro's parents. Sar Fernandez said
两年后，常驻波尔图的新警察团队利用鲁伊·佩德罗失踪后关键几小时内取得的证词，重建了他在接下来的24小时内可能遭遇的情况。由于这些努力，2011年2月11日，葡萄牙中央刑侦和起诉部对阿方索·迪亚斯（Afonso Dias）提起诉讼。迪亚斯作为这个已历时13年的案件中的长期头号嫌疑人，被指控犯有加重绑架罪。特谢拉·门多萨一家的律师里卡多·萨尔萨内斯（Ricardo Sar Sarnes）对检察官办公室在发出起诉书方面拖延了很长时间表示遗憾，但也对它表示欢迎，认为这是给鲁伊·佩德罗父母带来希望的一个机会。萨尔萨内斯说，
these efforts should have been made in the original investigation. Quote, During the 48 hours that followed the disappearance, the investigation failed to respect basic procedures and led to weeks, months, years going by with nothing being done. A preliminary hearing was held at Lozada's district court to determine whether Dias would be tried for the young boy's disappearance. Prosecutors maintained that on the afternoon of March 4, 1998, Dias drove Rui Pedro to visit sex workers before taking him to an unknown destination. They noted that Dias lacked an adequate alibi between 2pm and 6.45pm that day. Although he claimed he had been walking around the nearby city all afternoon,
这些工作本应在最初的调查中就做好。他引述道：“在失踪后的48小时内，调查未能遵循基本程序，导致数周、数月、数年的时间流逝而什么都没做。”洛扎达地方法院举行了初步听证会，以决定是否就这名男孩的失踪对迪亚斯进行审判。检方坚称，在1998年3月4日下午，迪亚斯开车带着鲁伊·佩德罗去拜访性工作者，随后将他带到了一个未知地点。他们指出，那天下午2点到6点45分之间，迪亚斯没有充分的不在场证明。尽管他声称自己整个下午都在附近城市四处走动，
he was unable to provide any specific locations. Prosecutors believed he knew what happened to Pedro, but refused to tell as it would implicate him in the abduction. In response, him in the abduction. In response, Deas declared himself a victim, claiming the allegations were quote, without factual support and that Huy Pedro did not enter his vehicle under such circumstances. He questioned the central testimony of the prosecution's key witnesses, including Huy Pedro's three friends who were present at the field on March 4 1998. As their statements were supplied over three different periods ranging from 1998 to 2008, Dias argued they were inaccurate and unreliable. He asserted that Alcina, the sex worker, gave an inaccurate description of the boys she saw
但他无法提供任何具体地点。检方认为他知道佩德罗发生了什么，但拒绝透露，因为这会牵连到他参与绑架。作为回应，他在绑架中。作为回应，迪亚斯声称自己是受害者，称这些指控“毫无事实依据”，并称鲁伊·佩德罗并非在这种情况下坐上他的车。他质疑检方关键证人的核心证词，包括在1998年3月4日出现在现场的鲁伊·佩德罗的三个朋友。由于他们的陈述是在1998年至2008年三个不同时期提供的，迪亚斯辩称这些陈述不准确且不可信。他断言，性工作者阿尔西娜（Alcinca）对她那天下午看到的男孩的描述并不准确，
on that afternoon, initially saying his eyes were blue before changing her statement to say they were dark brown. Dias also highlighted that the prosecution had no physical evidence to prove Juipedru had been in his car. He claimed, to prove Juipedru had been in his car. He claimed, As far as Juipedru is concerned, the thing I want most in the world is that he appears. I never denied being with him, but I never saw him again after we parted company that day, and I haven't a clue what happened to him. Despite his efforts to discredit the case against him, Alfonso Dias was formally accused of kidnapping and ordered to stand trial.
最初她说他的眼睛是蓝色的，后来又改口说眼睛是深棕色的。迪亚斯还强调，检方没有任何确凿证据证明鲁伊·佩德罗曾坐过他的车。他声称，为了证明鲁伊·佩德罗曾坐过他的车。他声称：“就鲁伊·佩德罗而言，我这世界上最想要的就是他出现。我从没否认过和他在一起，但自从那天我们分别后，我就再也没见过他，而且我根本不知道他身上发生了什么。”尽管他努力抹黑针对他的案件，阿方索·迪亚斯仍被正式指控绑架并被下令接受审判。
The purpose of the trial was not to determine exactly what happened to Huipedru, but to decide whether Dias was responsible for his disappearance. but to decide whether Dias was responsible for his disappearance. The accused continued to maintain his innocence while refusing to clarify exactly what happened on the afternoon Juan Pedro went missing. The trial began in the court of Lozada on November 17 2011. Dias, who was now 34 years old, requested to be excused from attending on the grounds that prolonged absence from his job as a long-distance truck driver would result in economic difficulties, but his request was denied. He also claimed to have cognitive difficulties that translated into an inability to, quote, situate himself in time and space and requested to undergo
审判的目的不是为了确定鲁伊·佩德罗究竟发生了什么，而是为了判定迪亚斯是否应当对他的失踪负责。但是为了判定迪亚斯是否应当对他的失踪负责。被告坚称自己无辜，同时拒绝澄清鲁伊·佩德罗失踪那天下午到底发生了什么。审判于2011年11月17日在洛扎达法院开庭。现年34岁的迪亚斯请求法院允许他免于出庭，理由是长期缺席长途卡车司机的职位会导致经济困难，但他的请求被驳回了。他还声称自己有认知困难，表现为无法“在时间和空间中定位自己”，并请求接受
psychological testing, but this request was also denied. Due to the amount of publicity surrounding the case and the public's hostility towards Diersch, the Lozada Municipal Police closed the streets surrounding the courthouse and increased their presence for the trial. Filomena Teixeira testified, detailing the moment she farewelled her son as he cycled towards the field behind her workplace. him, describing Dias as a childish person who, at the age of 22, played on an equal footing with her 11-year-old son and had consequently appeared harmless. Puyi Pedru's cousin, Joao André, also took the stand. The now-adult André told the court that on the day of his cousin's disappearance, Dias planned to take him and Tui Pedro to meet with sex workers, despite the fact they were both children.
心理测试，但这一请求同样被驳回。由于该案受到的广泛关注以及公众对迪亚斯的敌意，洛扎达市警察局封闭了法院周围的街道，并增派警力以确保审判安全。菲洛梅娜·特谢拉出庭作证，详细讲述了她向骑着自行车前往她工作地点背后田野的儿子告别的那一刻。他，将迪亚斯描述为一个幼稚的人，在22岁时还与她11岁的儿子处于同等的玩闹水平，因此显得毫无害处。鲁伊·佩德罗的表弟若昂·安德烈（Joao André）也出庭作证。现已成年的安德烈告诉法庭，在他表弟失踪的那天，迪亚斯曾计划带他和鲁伊·佩德罗去见性工作者，尽管他们当时都还是孩子。
As Andrzej missed the meeting, he believed he may have avoided becoming a victim himself. Plagued with survivor's guilt, he thought he could have saved his cousin from being kidnapped had he been there, saying, Being two, we might have had the strength to flee. Alcina, the sex worker who was approached by a man with a young boy on March 4 1998, also appeared in court. During her testimony, she was shown a photograph of 11-year-old Jorge Pedro and said she was absolutely certain it was him she met that day. When asked if the man who accompanied the child was sitting in the dock, Alcina stared at Dias for several seconds before replying, yes. The defence pointed out that during the investigation, Alcina never unequivocally identified the driver of the car as Alfonso Dias.
由于安德烈错过了那次聚会，他相信自己可能因此避免了成为受害者。饱受幸存者内疚折磨的他认为，如果当时自己在场，本可以救出被绑架的表弟，他说道：“如果我们两个人在一起，也许我们就有力气逃跑了。”阿尔西娜——那名在1998年3月4日被一个带着小男孩的男子接近的性工作者——也出庭了。在作证期间，她被出示了一张11岁鲁伊·佩德罗的照片，并表示她绝对确信那天遇到的人就是他。当被问及陪伴这名儿童的男子是否正坐在被告席上时，阿尔西娜盯着迪亚斯看了几秒钟，然后回答：“是的。”辩方指出，在调查期间，阿尔西娜从未明确认定汽车司机就是阿方索·迪亚斯。
She conceded this was correct, but explained the authorities had never attempted to help her formally identify the man, despite speaking with them on three separate occasions. She was finally able to do so in court, as it was the first time since the event she had seen Dias face to face A former judiciary police inspector who was involved in the investigation from its inception until 2001 Told the court he believed Rui Pedro may still be alive, noting I have no evidence, but that's my belief. Regarding Afonso Dias, the former officer remarked, There were some things that did not fit right. I could not materialise evidence that he was guilty or innocent.
她承认这是事实，但解释说当局从未试图帮她正式辨认这名男子，尽管她曾与他们有过三次单独的谈话。她最终得以在法庭上这样做，因为这是自事发以来她第一次与迪亚斯面对面。曾参与该案从创立到2001年调查的一名前司法警察探员告诉法庭，他相信鲁伊·佩德罗可能还活着，并指出：“我没有证据，但这是我的信念。”关于阿方索·迪亚斯，这名前警官评论道：“有些事情不太对劲。我无法将他有罪或无罪的证据实体化。”
He contested Alcina's statement, claiming that two days after Huipedru's disappearance, she said the man who approached her drove a white car, not a black one like Dias's. Huipedru's uncle, who accompanied the inspector to speak with Alcina during the initial investigation, rebutted this, maintaining that she had described a black vehicle. maintaining that she had described a black vehicle. The defence put forward a different timeline of events for the afternoon of Rui Pedro's disappearance, claiming he had met with Dias prior to riding his bike to visit his mother at her workplace. They argued that the prosecution was using Dias as a scapegoat and he was only being accused because of the animosity that had
他反驳了阿尔西娜的陈述，声称在鲁伊·佩德罗失踪两天后，她曾说接近她的那个男子开的是一辆白色的车，而不是像迪亚斯那样的黑车。鲁伊·佩德罗的叔叔在初步调查期间曾陪同探员与阿尔西娜交谈，他对此进行了反驳，坚称她描述的是一辆黑色的车辆。坚称她描述的是一辆黑色的车辆。辩方提出了关于鲁伊·佩德罗失踪那天下午的不同时间线，声称他在骑自行车去他母亲工作地点探望母亲之前曾与迪亚斯会面。他们辩称，检方是在拿迪亚斯当替罪羊，对他提出指控纯粹是因为在儿子失踪时，他们的当事人与鲁伊·佩德罗的父亲曼努埃尔（Manuel）之间积怨已深。他们声称曼努埃尔嫉妒迪亚斯花在妻子和儿子身上的时间，导致迪亚斯和菲洛梅娜对曼努埃尔隐瞒了他们的会面。曼努埃尔否认了这些指控，称他关心的始终只有迪亚斯和鲁伊·佩德罗之间的年龄差距。审理此案的法官小组以及几位证人和特谢拉-门多萨一家前往洛扎达的几个关键地点，重演了导致鲁伊·佩德罗失踪的情况。他们从特谢拉驾校后面的田野一直走到鲁克托扎（Luxtoza）性交易区，据说那是迪亚斯带走这个男孩的地方，
been brewing between their client and Rui Pedro's father Manuel at the time of his son's disappearance. They claimed Manuel was jealous of the amount of time Dias spent with his wife and son, resulting in Dias and Filomena concealing their meetings from him. Manuel denied these allegations, saying his main concern was only ever the age difference between Diez and Huipedru. The group of judges presiding over the case, along with several witnesses and the Teixeira-Mendonza family, travelled to key locations throughout Lozada to re-enact the circumstances leading to Huipedru's disappearance. They went from the field behind the Teixeira's driving school to the Luxtoza sex work zone, which was allegedly where Deix had taken the boy
也是他最后一次被看到的地方。菲洛梅娜选择和女儿留在车里，因为在调查初期阿尔西娜提供证词后，她就已经去过该地区寻找线索了。多年后再次来到这里给她带来了极大的悲伤，她不禁纳闷自己当时本可以做些什么来阻止儿子的失踪。曼努埃尔后来告诉《Caras》杂志，重温那最后一天是很艰难的，但他忍受了这一切，因为他相信这会有助于找到真相。检方要求判处阿方索·迪亚斯监禁，并指出他没有表现出任何悔意，
and the last place he was seen. Filomena chose to stay in the car with her daughter as she had already visited the area to search for clues after Alcina provided her statement at the outset of the investigation. Being there again so many years later brought her deep sorrow as she wondered what she could have done to prevent her son's disappearance. Manuel later told Cadres Magazine, it was difficult to relive that final day, but he endured it because he believed it would help find the truth. The prosecution requested Alfonso Dias be imprisoned, noting he had shown no sign of remorse and had
表现得极其冷漠。“我要求伸张正义，以解决这个案件。这个过程的终点是未能查明佩德罗遭遇什么的痛苦和煎熬。我们要求正义，并期待正义得以伸张。”2012年2月22日，在一个让许多人感到惊讶的结果中，阿方索·迪亚斯被判无罪。法官小组驳回了检方证人的证词，并采纳了辩方的辩词，即菲洛梅娜是最后一个见到鲁伊·佩德罗的人。这一判决是基于所谓的证据薄弱，特别是引用了“阿尔西娜证词缺乏一致性”这一说法。公众对这一裁决感到愤怒，一些聚集在
behaved with total indifference. Quote, I ask for justice for the resolution of the case. At the end of this process is the hurt and anguish at not finding out what happened to Pedro. We ask for justice and expect it to be done. On February 22 2012, in a result that surprised many, Alfonso Dias was acquitted. The panel of judges rejected the testimonies from the prosecution's witnesses and accepted the defence's argument that Philomena was the last person to have seen Huipedru. The decision was based on what was described as weaknesses in the evidence, citing in particular the, quote, lack of consistency in Alcina's testimony. Members of the public were outraged by the decision, with some who had gathered at the
法院门前期待有罪判决的人，在阿方索·迪亚斯重获自由离开时向他大声辱骂。无罪释放后，迪亚斯告诉RTP1电视台，他最后一次见到鲁伊·佩德罗是在1998年3月4日下午，当时他开车离开那个11岁男孩正在骑自行车的田野。迪亚斯此后已经结婚并育有一个9岁的儿子，他说他现在开始为家人的安全感到担忧。他对他们所遭受的痛苦感到遗憾，但对法院的判决表示宽慰。引述道：“但对法院的判决表示宽慰。引述道：‘当我回到家时，我对儿子说，事实证明，你父亲从来没有跟这事有任何关系。’”
courthouse in anticipation of a guilty verdict shouting abuse at Alfonso Dias as he left the free man. Following his acquittal, Dias told television station RTP1 that he last saw Rui Pedro on the afternoon of March 4 1998 when he drove away from the field where the 11-year-old was riding his bike. Deas, who had since married and had a 9-year-old son, said he now feared for his family's safety. He regretted the suffering they had endured but expressed relief at the court's decision. Quote, but expressed relief at the court's decision. Quote, When I got home, I said, Son, it's proven that your father never had anything to do with it.
他表示，在有确凿证据证明之前，他将继续相信鲁伊·佩德罗还活着。审判结果对菲洛梅娜产生了毁灭性的打击，导致她的身体和情感健康状况急剧恶化。她食欲不振，体重骤降至39公斤。特谢拉·门多萨一家向高等法院提起上诉，辩称审判法官依赖了本应被禁止的证据，特别是三名几乎没有对案件进行调查的探员的证词。尽管这几名探员缺乏参与度，但法院仍将他们视为可靠且知情的证人，尤其是在抹黑阿尔西娜的证词方面。
He stated he would continue to believe that Hoi Pedru was still alive until it was proven otherwise. The outcome of the trial had a devastating impact on Philomena, causing both her physical and emotional wellbeing to deteriorate significantly. She struggled to eat, with her weight plummeting to 39 kilograms. The Teixeira Mendonca family made a submission to the Court of Appeal, arguing that the trial judges had relied on evidence that should have been forbidden, specifically the testimony of three inspectors who did little to investigate the case. Despite their lack of involvement, the court had regarded the officers as reliable and informed witnesses, especially when it came to discrediting Alcina's testimony.
该家属的律师里卡多·萨尔萨南德斯（Ricardo Sarsa-nandes）声称，这名探员毫无根据的陈述毒害并污染了法院的裁决，并且“这项判决不是法官的判决，而是那三名探员的判决。”萨尔萨南德斯称，菲洛梅娜是最后一个见到她儿子的裁决简直不可思议，并表示：“嗯，这根本说不通。既然鲁伊·佩德罗已经和阿方索在一起过了，为什么他还要去求妈妈让自己跟阿方索出去呢？”驾校的其他员工之一也曾作证说，在失踪当天下午2点15分左右看到鲁伊·佩德罗去探望母亲，并无意中听到
The family's lawyer, Ricardo Sarsanandes, claimed the inspector's uninformed statements poisoned and infected the court's decision and that, quote, the judgment was not of the judges, but of the three inspectors. Sarsanandes called the ruling that Filomena was the last person to have seen her son unbelievable, stating, Well, that does not make any sense. Why was Juan Pedro going to ask his mother to go out with Alfonso when he had already been with him? One of the other driving school employees had also testified to seeing Rui Pedro visit his mother at approximately 2.15pm on the day of his disappearance and overheard
菲洛梅娜拒绝了他与迪亚斯会面的请求。萨尔萨南德斯称法院的裁决不可接受，并声明：“萨尔萨南德斯称法院的裁决不可接受，并声明：‘为了我们的历史，这个案件不能维持这个判决。我们欠鲁伊·佩德罗的记忆一个交代，无论他是死是活。我们也欠阿尔西娜一个交代，她是一个没有从中得到任何好处却说出真相的非凡女性。’”特谢拉·门多萨一家继续为重审而战，曼努埃尔表示：“在我们知道鲁伊·佩德罗发生了什么之前，我们将继续坚持下去。”而菲洛梅娜则再次呼吁伸张正义。无罪释放被高等法院谴责，重审定于2014年进行。
Filomena denying his request to meet with Deix. Sar Fernandez called the court's finding unacceptable, stating, Hernandez called the court's finding unacceptable, stating, This case cannot stay with this decision for the sake of our history. We owe this to the memory of Hojpedru, if he is dead or if he is alive. And we owe this to Alcina, an extraordinary woman who did not gain anything from it and told the truth. The Teixeira Mendonca family continued to fight for a retrial, with Manuel stating, Until we know what happened to Juan Pedro, we will continue, while Filomena once again called for justice to be done. The acquittal was condemned by the Court of Appeal and a retrial was scheduled for 2014.
尽管这个消息令人欣慰，但菲洛梅娜质疑自己是否有足够的体力来承受更多的法律折磨。随着重审的临近，曼努埃尔解释说：“在得知案件将要重审后，我妻子设法恢复了一点，现在体重达到了47公斤，但随着审判的临近，她又停止进食，变得更加虚弱了。”医生们担心她会再次变得非常消瘦。又会变得骨瘦如柴。菲洛梅娜焦虑万分，需要住院并通过管子进食。当人们担心她是否能够出庭作证时，曼努埃尔告诉媒体：“她必须这么做，她也会这么做，因为这对他来说非常重要。”
Although this news was favourable, Philomena questioned whether she had the strength to continue with more legal ordeals. As the retrial approached, Manuel explained, After learning that the case was going to retrial, my wife managed to recover a little and now weighs 47 kilograms, but as she approached the trial, she stopped eating again and became more fragile. The doctors feared that she would become very thin again. would become very thin again. Philomena was overwhelmed with anxiety and required hospitalisation to be fed through a tube. When concerns arose whether she would be able to testify, Manuel told the media, She has to do it and she will because he is very important to her.
会的，因为这对他来说非常重要。重审在波尔图上诉法院开庭。菲洛梅娜是新法官小组面前首批作证的证人之一，她再次在公众面前重温了她最后一次见到儿子的情景。在双方第二次陈述各自的案件后，法官们权衡了证据并得出结论。他们接受了阿方索·迪亚斯确实曾将鲁伊·佩德罗从田野带去见阿尔西娜的事实。由于企图让这名11岁的男孩与性工作者发生接触，迪亚斯被裁定犯有腐蚀未成年人罪。法官们得出结论，迪亚斯是鲁伊·佩德罗失踪前最后与其在一起的人。然而，他们认为没有足够的证据证明他应对
will, because he is very important to her. The retrial commenced at the Appellate Court of Porto. Philomena was one of the first witnesses to testify before a new panel of judges, and once again publicly relived the last time she saw her son. After both sides had presented their cases for the second time, the judges considered the evidence and reached a conclusion. They accepted Alfonso Dias had indeed taken Rui Pedro from the field to visit Alcina. For his attempt to make the 11-year-old engage with sex workers, Dias was found guilty for corruption of a minor. The judges concluded Dias was the last person in Rui Pedro's company before he vanished. However, they believed there wasn't enough evidence to prove he was responsible for
失踪本身负责，因此他并未被判犯有绑架该男孩的罪名。他并未被判犯有绑架该男孩的罪名。2013年3月4日，即鲁伊·佩德罗失踪整整15周年之际，迪亚斯被判处三年六个月监禁。特谢拉-门多萨一家的律师里卡多·萨尔萨南德斯评论道：“对我来说，这是非常重要的一天，对菲洛梅娜和曼努埃尔来说也非常重要，但最重要的是，这对鲁伊·佩德罗来说是极其重要的一天，因为鲁伊·佩德罗可能还活着，我们将继续寻找他。如果他已经不在人世，他的记忆也值得我们坚持下去，直到我们知道他到底发生了什么。这是第一场胜利，但不是最后一场。最后的胜利将是我们得知他究竟遭遇了什么的时候。”菲洛梅娜赞扬了法院的裁决，称其为一丝希望之光，也是隧道尽头的一线光明。
the disappearance itself and he was not convicted of the boy's abduction. itself and he was not convicted of the boy's abduction. On March 4 2013, 15 years to the day after Juan Pedro's disappearance, Dias was sentenced to three years and six months in prison. Ricardo Sarsenandes, the Teixeira-Mendoza family's lawyer, remarked, For me, this is a very important day, very important for Philomena and for Manuel, but it is above all a very important day for Juan Pedro, because Juan Pedro may be alive and we will continue the search for him. And if he is not alive, his memory deserves that we carry on until we know what happened to him. It is the first victory, but not the last. The last victory will be when we know what happened to him. Filomena praised the court's decision, calling it a glimmer of hope and a little light at the end of the tunnel.
2015年3月18日，在用尽所有可能的上诉途径后，迪亚斯在葡萄牙北部城市吉马良斯开始了他的刑期。两年后，即2017年3月下旬，他在服满三分之二刑期后因表现良好获得假释。他提前出狱让菲洛梅娜感到失望，听到这个消息时，她被极度的情感和肉体疲劳压垮了。她后来向《Flash》杂志的记者描述了自己的反应，并表示：“我感到无比反感。我很遗憾自己生活在一个人们和机构都不是它们应有样子的国家里。我认为不公正的事情越来越多。”她儿子失踪的每一个周年纪念日对菲洛梅娜来说都极其痛苦，因为那感觉就像他是在昨天才刚刚消失一样。
On March 18 2015, after exhausting all possible avenues of appeal, Dias began his prison sentence in the northern Portuguese city of Guimarães. Two years later, in late March 2017, he was paroled for good behaviour after serving just two-thirds of his sentence. His early release came as a disappointment to Filomena, who was overcome by emotional and physical exhaustion when she heard the news. She later described her reaction to reporters from Flash magazine, stating, I feel such a great revulsion. I am sorry to live in a country where people and institutions are not what they should be. I think there is more and more injustice. Each anniversary of her son's disappearance was extremely painful for Philomena, as it felt like he had only vanished yesterday.
她经常梦见他与妹妹快乐地玩耍，并幻想着他长大后的模样。菲洛梅娜觉得鲁伊·佩德罗会像小时候一样一直保持着微笑，她说：“我怀抱着希望，他现在是一个身材魁梧的高个子男人。我真不敢想象我将如何紧紧地拥抱他。”阿方索·迪亚斯坚称自己无辜，坚称自己为一个并未犯下的罪行服了刑。他告诉《每日新闻报》（Jornal de Notícias）的记者，他真的是一个自由人，因为他从来没有对任何人做过任何事。在接受葡萄牙一个热门新闻节目的采访时，他说他警告警方在鲁伊·佩德罗失踪后不久关闭边界的话只是在讽刺。引述道：“他的爷爷以为我把这孩子扔到了卡车后面，”在同一次采访中，他多次称阿尔西娜为婊子和荡妇，
She often dreamt of him playing happily with his sister and imagined the man he would have become. Filomena felt Juipedru would still be constantly smiling as he did when he was a boy, saying, I am hopeful that he is a tall man with a strong structure. I can only imagine the hug I am going to give him. Alfonso Dias maintained his innocence, insisting that he served time for a crime he didn't commit. He told a journalist from National Daily newspaper, Jornal de Notícias, that he was truly a free man because he never rode anything to anyone. In an interview with a popular Portuguese news program, he said the warning he gave police to close the borders shortly after Rui Pedro went missing was sarcastic. Quote, His grandad thought I threw the kid onto the back of a truck, so the same interview, he referred to Alsina as a bitch and a whore multiple times,
促使采访者插话打断。促使采访者插话打断。随着鲁伊·佩德罗失踪16周年纪念日的临近，电影制作人克劳迪娅·克莱门特（Claudia Clemente）利用社交媒体传播对这起未破案件的关注，她担心阿方索·迪亚斯的定罪可能会误导葡萄牙人民，让他们以为调查已经结束。在视听和传讯专业团队的帮助下，她制作了一个90秒的网络视频活动，其中两位主持人回忆了一系列通常与家人共度的特别时刻，并说道：“那些年充满了新闻、惊喜和欢笑。他们随后提出了这样一个问题：‘你还记得和儿子在一起的最后这些年吗？’”屏幕逐渐变黑，随后菲洛梅娜·特谢拉出现，强忍着泪水评论道：“我记不清了。今天我的儿子佩德罗27岁了。自从他11岁起我就再也没见过他。”
prompting the interviewer to interject. the interviewer to interject. When the 16th anniversary of Rui Pedro's disappearance approached, filmmaker Claudia Clemente used social media to spread awareness about the unsolved case, fearing the conviction of Afonso Dias might have misled the Portuguese people into thinking the investigation was over. With the help of a team of audiovisual and communications professionals, she created a 90-second online video campaign in which two presenters reminisce about a range of special occasions typically spent with family, stating, Those were years filled with news, surprises, and laughter. They then pose the question, do you remember these last years with your son? The screen fades to black before Filomena Teixeira appears and remarks whilst blinking back tears, I don't. Today my son Pedro turns 27. I haven't seen him since he was 11.
我永远不会放弃寻找他。根据该活动的数据，截至2014年，全球已有超过300万名儿童被拐卖用于性剥削。全球已被拐卖用于性剥削。视频以以下请求结束：“如果您有任何可能帮助我们找到鲁伊·佩德罗的信息，请告知我们。帮助他人永远不会嫌迟。失踪的是菲洛梅娜的儿子，但也有可能是你的儿子。”但也有可能是你的儿子。到2017年，菲洛梅娜因残疾而退休，她通过照顾女儿、尝试各种疗法以及继续寻找儿子来让自己保持忙碌。她将鲁伊·佩德罗的卧室保持着他在1998年离开时的原样，里面有他太空主题的被套、整齐陈列的玩具车和手办、电子游戏机，以及挂在门后的一张美国女演员桑德拉·布洛克的巨幅海报。菲洛梅娜唯一添加的东西是一些圣徒的画像、
I'll never give up looking for him. According to the campaign, by 2014, more than 3 million children had been abducted around the world for sexual exploitation. abducted around the world for sexual exploitation. The video concludes with the following request. If you have any information that may help us locate Hojpedru, please let us know. It is never too late to help. It was Filomena's son who disappeared, but it could have been yours. but it could have been yours. By 2017, Filomena had retired due to disability and kept busy by taking care of her daughter, exploring various therapies, and continuing to search for her son. She kept Juy Pedro's bedroom exactly as he had left it in 1998, complete with his space-themed quilt cover, neat display of toy cars and action figures, video game console, and a poster of American actress Sandra Bullock hanging behind the door. The only things Philomena added were some images of saints
由灯光照亮的十字架和一本圣经，她说：“由灯光照亮的十字架和一本圣经，她说：‘我在等他回来，告诉我们他想改变什么。’”那一年，在儿子失踪19周年纪念日那天，菲洛梅娜在Facebook上发布了一则呼吁，恳求公众继续寻找他。她说，虽然她的家人已经适应了新的现实，但这场悲剧导致她变得孤立，并且不确定该信任谁。她写道：“鲁伊·佩德罗，你的内心深处知道我仍然相信奇迹，否则我就不会活到现在了，我正张开双臂等待你归来，给你一个紧紧的拥抱。”
illuminated by lamps, a crucifix, and a bible, saying, by lamps, a crucifix and a bible, saying, I'm waiting for him to come back to tell us what he wants to change. That year, on the 19th anniversary of her son's disappearance, Philomena posted an appeal on Facebook imploring the public to continue looking for him. She said that while her family had adapted to their new reality, the tragedy had caused her to become isolated and uncertain of who to trust. She wrote, Puyo Pedro, you know deep down I still believe in miracles, otherwise I would not be alive, and I wait for you with open arms for a tight hug.
请不要忘记。答应我，你不会忘记他，如果我发生了什么意外，请继续战斗，去查明他究竟遭遇了什么。这是我仅剩的一切。只有身为母亲的人才能体会这种渴望的绝望。请不要忘记他。永远不要放弃。2018年，一个在社交媒体上流传的葡萄牙流浪汉视频引起了全国新闻媒体的注意。这个蓄着胡子的男人身材苗条、皮肤黝黑、有，蓄着胡子、皮肤黝黑，
Do not forget, please. Promise me you will not forget him, and if anything happens to me, keep fighting to know what happened to him. That's all I have left. This despair of longing that only those who are mothers feel. Please do not forget it. Never give up. In 2018, a video of a homeless Portuguese man circulating on social media caught the attention of national news outlets. The bearded man was lean with tanned skin, lets. The bearded man was lean with tanned skin, had dark hair and eyes, and bore other striking similarities to Hoi Pedro. He said his name was Pedro and that he was 30 years old, which roughly matched the age Hoi Pedro would have been at the time. However, he was born and raised in Almada, a city located in southern Portugal,
有着黑色的头发和眼睛，并且与鲁伊·佩德罗有着其他惊人的相似之处。他说他叫佩德罗，今年30岁，这大致符合鲁伊·佩德罗当时应有的年龄。然而，他在阿尔马达（Almada）出生并长大，这是一座位于葡萄牙南部的城市，
approximately 350 kilometres south of Lozada. The video was shared thousands of times and sent to the Teixeira Mendonça family. Manuel noted the man in the footage shared some physical characteristics to his son, including large front teeth, but also noticed obvious differences, such as the shape of his ears. The video was sent to the authorities for further analysis and the judicial police managed to identify the individual. It was not Huy Pedro, but a man called Pedro Hebelu. Pui Pedro, but a man called Pedro Hebelu.
位于洛扎达以南约350公里处。这段视频被分享了数千次，并被发送给了特谢拉·门多萨一家。曼努埃尔指出，录像中的男子与他的儿子有一些共同的身体特征，包括突出的门牙，但也注意到明显的差异，例如耳朵的形状。这段视频已被送交有关部门作进一步分析，司法警察成功确认了该个体的身份。他不是鲁伊·佩德罗，而是一个名叫佩德罗·赫贝鲁（Pedro Hebelu）的男子。普伊·佩德罗，而是一个名叫佩德罗·赫贝鲁的男子。
In January 2019, Filomena was interviewed by Portuguese television host Cristina Ferreira, during which she discussed how the search for her son had sent her into the dark world of pedophilia. She said she had cried so much that she had no more tears left, but made it clear that she did not mourn for her son as she believed he was alive. In response to her doctor's recommendation to place a memorial stone in Hojpedru's bedroom, Filomena said, You want me to put a grave in my son's room. My son is missing, not dead. Many continue to suspect that Afonso Dias was involved in Rui Pedro's disappearance,
2019年1月，菲洛梅娜接受了葡萄牙电视节目主持人克里斯蒂娜·费雷拉（Cristina Ferreira）的采访，在采访中她谈到了寻找儿子的经历是如何将她推入恋童癖黑暗世界的。她说过自己哭得厉害，以至于眼泪都流干了，但她明确表示她并没有为儿子服丧，因为她坚信他还活着。针对医生建议在鲁伊·佩德罗的卧室里放置一块纪念石的建议，菲洛梅娜说：“你想让我把一座坟墓放在我儿子的房间里吗？我儿子是失踪了，而不是死了。”许多人仍然怀疑阿方索·迪亚斯参与了鲁伊·佩德罗的失踪，
with the general belief being that he took the child to sex workers to lose his virginity in preparation for selling him to a pedophile ring. There is evidence to prove the Wonderland Club had roots in Portugal, with at least one member living in the country at the time the group was exposed. Filomena believes Dias may have been a victim of blackmail, who was forced to play a role in her son's disappearance, but remains silent out of fear. in her son's disappearance, but remained silent out of fear. The Teixeira Mendonça family and the Portuguese public remain hopeful that Dias will one day break his silence and reveal the truth, with Manuel urging him to imagine what it would be like to live without his own child for so many years. On Rui Pedro's 32nd birthday, Filomena wrote a message that read, Son, I remember you in a mixture of emotions, joy and sadness. Joy because I had you and you
普遍的看法是，他带着这个孩子去见性工作者以失去童贞，以此为将他贩卖给恋童癖团伙做准备。有证据证明“仙境俱乐部”（Wonderland Club）在葡萄牙有根基，当该组织被曝光时，至少有一名成员居住在该国。菲洛梅娜相信迪亚斯可能是勒索的受害者，被迫在儿子失踪事件中扮演了某个角色，但由于恐惧而保持沉默。在他儿子失踪一事中，但由于恐惧而选择保持沉默。特谢拉·门多萨一家和葡萄牙公众仍然希望迪亚斯能有一天打破沉默并揭露真相，曼努埃尔敦促他想象一下，多年来没有自己的孩子相伴是一种什么样的生活。在鲁伊·佩德罗32岁生日那天，菲洛梅娜写下了一条信息：“儿子，我在百感交集、悲喜交加中想念你。高兴是因为我曾拥有你，你是
were part of me. Sadness because they took you and I did not have the opportunity to see you grow from the age of 11. On this day, I hope you will remember how much you have made me happy. I do not want to think I will never see you again. Today is your day, January 28, 2019. I await your arrival. Kiss and hug. Mother. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的一部分。难过的是他们带走了你，我没有机会看着你从11岁起长大成人。在这个日子里，我希望你能记住你曾让我多么快乐。我不想去想我再也见不到你了。今天是你的日子，2019年1月28日。我等待你的归来。亲吻和拥抱。母亲。谢谢。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。